how would you say that the relationship
between Liz and red has really changed
essentially with him being in jail and
her being outside of it but also knowing
that she's keeping the secret that she
put him in there
well Reddington is a very imposing
presence in Liz's life so to have him
out of the equation has been a huge
change of pace for Liz she has a lot
more freedom to pursue the answer she's
looking for would you say revenge is the
right word in terms of how she's
approaching this quest to find answers I
don't think that her quest is really
about him in any way I think it has much
more to do with what she wants for her
life and he always gets in the way of
what she's after so that's why she
checked him to the to the what is it the
ropes yes so I don't think it's about
him necessarily I think she checked him
to the I don't think it's about him
necessarily I think she checked him to
the ropes in order to like pursue what
she needs to for her own life so it's
not about revenge as much as it's about
pursuing what she would otherwise pursue
and he would get in the way of now is
she torn by putting him in there because
I get the sense as when we're watching
Liz she's upset seeing him in there even
though she wants his answers yeah I
certainly think that Liz is an empathic
character so she's not gonna be able to
turn off her feelings about Reddington
being behind bars and his life
potentially being at risk now I read the
tagline is two can play his game how
much fun is that for you being able to
play that I don't know that you know
that's the tagline the the way they lure
you in but it's not really playing out
that way liz is still is and red is
still red and red is a much more fun
character liz has got a lot on her
shoulders and let's sort of always been
the case and I roll with it but what's
really nice is having sort of her own
autonomy yeah and now Liz has questions
Dembe has answers what can we expect
from that relationship and kind of how
that will evolve this season
well you never really know how far dem
BAE's loyalty is going to take him with
Reddington especially because you've
seen behind the scenes free season after
season Dembe will say to Reddington you
need to tell her the truth so he
obviously has his his moral compass is
sort of pointing to having some loyalty
to Liz in this situation so which is
that like for us is like for as a beer I
can't wait to see how that's gonna
unfold how would you describe this
season for people people who've seen the
first few episodes or people who are
just getting into how would you describe
this season compared to what we've seen
in the past well this season everything
has turned on its head a bit with red in
jail and I think having him out of the
equation really changes the dynamic in
the war room
Liz truly is once again the only
lifeline between red and the outside
world and she brings she's his messenger
for the war room and so in some ways
that means we're sort of back to the way
we began where he would only speak to
Elizabeth keen and in a lot of ways you
can see how the series has evolved now
this show has so many twists and turns
for you as an actress when you're
reading like do you still get surprised
or is this you're expecting this now I
think I get I get surprised I'm I'm
really glad that they they make these
episodes fresh and new and sometimes I
really feel like they hit on by creating
this formula where you have these new
black Lister's every week and really
strange interesting characters that very
interesting new york-based actors would
love to play because they don't have to
leave their their backyard you know that
kind of thing I think that they really
they really hit on something and so what
excites me just as much as the plot
twists
is what I see like an actor's name on
the on the call sheet that I really love
that's gonna come join us and that
happens a lot in this series this show
has such a strong fan base such a loyal
following what are you excited for the
fans to see as these characters unravel
in the storylines unravel this season
what am i excited for them to see um I
hope I just you know I I'm always very
appreciative to the to the fan base the
people who like to watch the show and my
hope is that we continue to Surprise
them and entertain them and I think that
this season will I I think this is the
strongest season that we've had of the
show so far so that's my biggest hope to
me in terms of characters storylines or
just everything yeah I think the
overarching storyline of Liz looking for
the true identity of the imposter
Raymond Reddington is very interesting I
think that was a really interesting
reveal at the end of season 5 because it
turns to the whole series on its head in
a way and I also am excited by the
blacklister is I think the one that
we're shooting right now Lady Luck is
really great I think that they've come
up somehow in season six deep into the
marathon some really interesting
characters if you could steal an
identity for DES who to be I would
probably steal my mother's identity
because I just I feel like it would give
me a lot of understanding of her in her
life and that's something that I think
women should have is an is an
understanding of their mother an
appreciation yeah yeah an appreciation
that's what I mean is like a compassion
and empathy that a deeper empathy so
that's what I would do that's such a
better answer than I thought not that I
didn't think you're gonna give me a good
answer so maybe it's a celebrity right I
like that one that one's actually
awesome what's it like and then just
finishing up what's it like being on set
and being in a room like this when here
working on a show with just so much
detail going on I've walked in in this
whole place is so well this is my home I
mean this is for better or worse I've
lived here for six years now so I'm very
comfortable here it would be like
anywhere you've lived most people
haven't lived anywhere for six years
straight so I mean it's a home I'm very
familiar with these walls and these
desks and this this this gray hue and
that's something that the performers
don't really get your most of the time
you step on a set and there's like
heightened awareness I hate and sense of
consciousness because you are unfamiliar
so all you have your feelers up you know
but this one I'm very very i really cozy
here some of the fans want to know do
you think we could ever see a new
amsterdam and the blacklist crossover I
wouldn't do it I don't think I would do
a New Amsterdam crossover I'm really
happy for Ryan he's he's a really good
guy and I'm glad he's finding some great
success no he's too good for me now it
was a true story my husband's birthday
party I'm mad he said he was going to oh
I need to we need to call him I know
does anybody have Ryan's number I don't
anymore I erased it it says do not
answer this it's a jerk anyone who looks
at Ryan knows he's not a jerk he's very
um
you